les chefs d'entreprise sont mobilisés
pour permettre alors salle à leurs
collaborateurs de continuer à travailler
pour ceux qui sont autorisés à le faire
à utiliser principalement le télétravail
quand c'est possible et quand c'est
impossible
il incite effectivement leurs
collaborateurs à se présenter à leur
poste
ça se passe dans des conditions de
discussions de concertations parce que
si les salariés se présenta au travail
il y avait effectivement des consignes
de protection à respecter et nous sommes
déterminés à ce que l'activité
économique ne soit pas totalement à
l'arrêt mais qu'elle continue bien sûr
dans des conditions de sécurité maximale
quels sont les effets les inquiétudes
les principales inquiétudes ressenties
par les chefs d'entreprise les
principales inquiétudes vous savez quand
une entreprise est à l'arrêt elle puise
donc c'est dans sa trésorerie
et s'il n'y a pas de chiffres c'est la
trésorerie d'entreprise qui permet à
l'entreprise de répondre à ces à ses
besoins en termes de factures en termes
de salaires en termes de charge en
termes d'impôts etc etc
l'inquiétude si vous voulez c'est
comment ça va se passer
notamment pour ceux qui veulent faire
bénéficier leurs salariés du chômage
partiel
comment ça va se passer pour régler les
taxes et les charges qui arrive
comment ça va se passer avec les banques
parce qu'il va falloir aller chercher du
financement pour répondre aux besoins
actuels
bien entendu les investissements
aujourd'hui sont un arrêt parce que on
ne pas qu'on n'a plus de projet
aujourd'hui notre projet c'est de voir
un peu ce qui se passe et attendre la
reprise de l'activité
dernière question aux acariens hardy
temps la reprise aura lieu est ce que
vous serez vous êtes plutôt optimiste
pour la reprise ou pas du tout écoutez
moi je peux vous dire une chose c'est
mon sentiment personnel
legault de l'état ne pourra pas sauver
tout le monde et c'est pourquoi nous
invitons toutes les parties que ça soit
entrepreneurs chefs d'entreprise
salariés à ce que l'activité en france
ne s'arrête pas il ne faut pas paralyser
la france parce que la reprise et le
redémarrage va être extrêmement
difficile maintenant je ne veux pas
donner un message d'inquiétude d'angoise
ou jouer le pessimiste forcené j'y crois
parce que nous avons des collaborateurs
motivés
nous avons des collaborateurs qui
veulent que l'entreprise continue la
reprise va être difficile parce que le
le les entreprises vont fonctionner sur
leurs enfants trésorerie elles vont
solliciter des aides financières
nous verrons donc elles mesurent toutes
ces aides que l'état a mis en place vont
suffire vont fonctionner vont permettre
la reprise et le redémarrage de
l'activité économique en france